bonjour je m'appelle hélène de jeu de
santé sur huit ans je fais b j je suis
membre de l'équipe de france
[Musique]
à 18 ans mélanie s'est imposé dans le
cercle fermé des gymnastes de haut
niveau elle a décroché le titre de
championne d'europe au sol en août
dernier à glasgow
une médaille de plus dans son palmarès
où le bronze et l'argent côte ou alors
mélanie est l'une des favoris de la nuit
des champions ou d'autres étoiles rêve
également de briller rébellion
j'habitais s&p mont fuji au projet et de
faire partie de l'équipe de france
discipline à la police je m'appelle
aurait marre et simple cela fait quatre
ans que je signe son entrée au club des
cultures
je me rappelle michael stanislas
actuellement sociétaire de miss
martinique pour mickaël 2018 aurait une
grande année vainqueur du trophée de la
caraïbe champion de martinique
vainqueur du tour de martinique il est
aussi champion de la caraïbe de cyclisme
sur route
michael est l'un des favoris de la nuit
des champions ou d'autres étoiles rêve
également de brebis manech tamera je
suis licencié au made in athlétisme
maximale sophie j'ai 22 ans je voudrais
cependant des sports je suis même dit
qu'on soit ni
or l'année 2018 aura été une bonne année
pour mendy elle a décroché la médaille
d'or sur 100 m en août dernier aux
championnats d'europe handisport à
berlin c'est la deuxième fois qu'elle
remporte ce titre
mendy est l'une des favoris de la nuit
des champions ou d'autres étoiles rêve
également de briller une nouvelle jean
daniel
je suis judoka de haut niveau titulaire
en équipe de france de judo en 66 kg au
palmarès cette année c'est tout d'abord
une place de quatrième aux jeux prat
banques deux tiers de châteauroux
[Musique]